freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher kochen
und die heutige folge
ich weiß nicht sagt das fast immer ist
sehr besonders unser gas ist schon hier
im moment und zwar verlor er ist der
heutige kraft ich bin ihr sehen können
in der neuen umgebung ich bin in der wg
von meiner freundin und verhältnis der
rundfunk mitbewohnerin meiner freundin
der hat mir gesagt hat schon richtig
hunger oder ja ich freue mich schon sehr
auf das essen glaube ich nämlich auch
zum frühstück hast du dir von mir eine
beule würde es nämlich im gips arango
wie man unschwer erkennen kann was
laberst du ich gehe einfach gut die
wohnlage mit bananen blau wäre
merkel und jung lässt was willst du
jetzt schon wieder machen wie man essen
ja ich war eigentlich schon ich hoffe
dass dieser ganze hier war das
firmenkunden zu warten und und ich wir
sind halt so
dementsprechend wird es bestimmt ein
guter tag ich denke du wirst das super
machen
wir gehen im prinzip kochen wir gar
nicht viel beim frühstück tiere den
ganzen tag über rein hunde essen ja
nicht super viel gewürze das bringt um
dem erkläre ich dass ich muss dazu sagen
dass sam hat mich ein bisschen bekehrt
ich würde mich als ich zehn jahre alt
war von einem hund gebissen in den
oberschenkel von so einem großen teil
martina die mich eigentlich gut kannte
und mit dem ich mich verstanden habe und
der völlig verwirrt und habe mir in fein
gebissen und musste ins krankenhaus und
sonst was uns ab dem zeitpunkt mochte
ich eigentlich überhaupt keine hunde
werden hat auch lange zeit ziemlich
angst vor hunden bis ich meine freundin
wird in der wg ist und die familie hat
nun überall so plötzlich hunde und ich
habe festgestellt die sind gar nicht so
falsch grashalm ist wirklich der beste
der empfängt mich immer wenn ich aus dem
aufzukommen und dafür bedanke ich mich
jetzt heute einfach
therapiert hat ja du warst am anfang ein
kleiner schild komplett in der ecke
weniger reden und mehreren sagen die ich
heute kochen sind natürlich mit sam
bauten abgestellt also er kann auch
alles essen was ich heute kochen oder es
sind spezielle runde rezepte es ist
außerdem alles auch für menschen essbar
aber ich glaube so um gewürzt und so
schmeckt zeitig besonders gut ich werde
es trotzdem probieren verwehrt da drüben
jetzt die fahne heißt wird willst du
selbst auch interessiert sondern kochen
nein nur am essen du lässt das dann eher
für dich machen oder wie ja ich habe
hunger bitte macht schnell wir gehen mal
den weg in die pfanne nicht zu viel so
drei scheiben nicht schon gut oder
ja und wie ich liebe beeck und bevor ihr
euch denkt zu jahren moment mal
normalerweise kochst du doch eigentlich
nur so für influenza und so sah es
tatsächlich auch influenza werden
instagram account wurde coole bilder von
sich postet und er ist auch sehr aktiv
dementsprechend sollte das eigentlich
cool sein für alle zu warten mit dem
vacant ich habe mir übrigens mit
lockenkopf gekauft das habe ich bei
meinem weg ins kochen nicht über kenji
gesehen und ich konnte es ist eine geile
perspektive erzählen wie läuft es bei
dir da hinten deine hand riecht nach
peking
freust du dich auf becken dann mal neu
ist übrigens er spricht englisch sam
lake freust du dich auf papa so caspar
sie haben ein paar blaubeeren gekauft
wie wahrscheinlich mal eben in die bol
com tarnów banane joghurt und
heidelbeeren also versteht man erst mal
unseren joghurt es ist vielleicht für
menschen ein bisschen komische
komposition aber ist ja nichts kann man
da ist überhaupt kein problem also
erstmal ein joghurt rein
das sollte erstmal reichen
sam hat extra seit gestern nichts
gegessen weil er sich so gefreut hat
auch das video banane schälen brauchen
wir gar nicht so super viel schneide ich
mal so ein paar schöne scheiben raus
was natürlich bei einer paul immer
wichtig ist dass man das ganze auch so
schön style also ein bisschen drüber mit
einem löffel so ein paar bananen dazu
glauben marke auch sehr gerne
sodann der bacon ist jetzt auch fertig
lassen wir noch kurz abkühlen hier auf
dem brettchen so jetzt baue ich es halo
ebenso einen tisch auf
[Musik]
ha hilfe wie isst man das wie
funktioniert eine schippe ich verstehe
es einfach nicht vielleicht ist das doch
nichts mit dem tisch hier und jetzt nach
so aha jetzt versteht ja lecker du
kannst alles essen ja ich habe es ja
jetzt verstanden hat den becken das
schon mal zehn von zehn ist er richtig
will sagen wir uns gleich wieder wenn du
aufgegessen acht okay ja und jetzt geht
er ja okay das war das frühstück wie ich
sehe hast du nicht alles ganz auf
gegessen was für besonders gut gefallen
das hat man gemerkt hast du auch als
erstes der yoga auf ganz gut da ja der
war super aber die laut wehren waren
nicht mein fall habe ich auch gemerkt
weil blaubeeren haben wir noch ein paar
hier
du hast ja dann auch die man nur so
haben wir im jahr das ja auch immer so
wie in joghurt war sie da ein bisschen
abgelegt und so wäre bleibt am ende
liegen was geht zu den wänden decken und
joghurt wie gesagt ob blaubeeren nicht
banane okay also siebeneinhalb okay sie
mein halt ja wie man halt würde ich
sagen ist solide jetzt habe ich jetzt
ein super verausgabt war ja ein
schnelles frühstück und dementsprechend
hoffe ich dass du nicht trotzdem auch
das mit einem essen freut keinen bock
mehr
wir kommen jetzt auch somit ein essen
hast du schon hunger ja und jetzt lasst
mich zählt hatte ich zum mittagessen von
wir ein hühnerfrikassee für hunde
gewünscht dazu habe ich ein spezielles
rezept gefunden und ihr seht das ist
quasi von saints row getestet von lupold
wir brauchen dafür 400 100 gramm
50 gramm meist 100 gramm frischkäse und
ein beutel kaufpreis ich war zunächst
weil die hühnerbrust ach du machst das
schön groß die gemachten mussten wir da
noch ab da bin ich wieder
zeig mal her aber nicht essen gleich das
war ja meinetwegen ich weiß ja ok freue
mich danke damit auch schon seit zwei
töpfe aufzusetzen ein für das
hühnchenfleisch und ein für den reis
beschreiben wir die härchen wo ist in
kleine stücke falls ihren rund haben
solltet und ihm auch was davon kocht
dann packt mich unbedingt bei instagram
story macht ich wusste selbst gar nicht
dass das gibt dave hat mir erzählt dass
man das bfn nennen wenn man für seine
runde normal kocht ist auf jeden fall
kasko mit mit wenn wir das jeden tag
macht wirklich so da mache ich weiter
mit einer möhre das ist auch dem
gleichen bretten normalerweise macht man
es natürlich nicht aber die möhre kommt
sowieso mit in den topf mit dem hähnchen
im entsprechenden monat schneiden
halbiere ich die möhre wirtschaftlich
sind feine scheiben sind die vitamine
das natürlich die schale dran weil das
hätten wir uns hier auch gesund ernähren
so ihr seht hier das wasser kocht schon
ich gebe jetzt als erstes mal das
hühnchen rein kommst dann bist du schon
ein bisschen rohkost sowie gehen wir
jetzt mal das hühnchen in den topf
hinein und da kommen wir es jetzt so
zehn minuten lang vor erreichbar auch
auf circa zehn minuten dann gebe ich
einfach auch schon mal rein und können
wir in der zwischenzeit ja spielen wohin
geh ja ich hole bringt komme ja schon
hier goodbye danke und so der timer ist
abgelaufen
das heißt wir gehen jetzt ein hähnchen
die restlichen gehören dazu und das sie
braucht eigentlich nur zehn minuten
gekocht ein bisschen länger damit so
weiter wird
wir brauchen noch ein bisschen mais und
den schritt ich mal ab da brauchen wir
davon 50 gramm pulver sisters zeig mal
her
nein das mag ich nicht mag sie nicht das
ist kein gutes zeichen aber vielleicht
stört sie nicht im hühnerfrikassee drin
samy bringt okay ich komme
was wirst du vergessen was meinst du du
hast vergessen ja was der sagt auch gerd
okay kein bock mehr okay wir kochen
weiter es dürfte langsam durch sein so
es ist jetzt gleich soweit ich nehme
schon mal den raum und ich mache mir
jetzt natürlich gleich auch eine
menschen portion von dem essen lecker
hand die liga auch leckere ja so heraus
jetzt schütten wir das ganze aber nicht
ganz alles ein bisschen früher behalten
wir so und in die brühe geben jetzt die
50 gramm mais und 100 gramm frischkäse
das rühren wir jetzt ein bis der
frischkäse ganz aufgelöst ist
so jetzt war auch schon unser reis dazu
dann würden wir auch unter und zum
abschluss das hähnchen mit den karotten
[Musik]
guten appetit rein da yahoo weniger
zurückhaltung auf jeden fall beim ersten
mal zu die haben jetzt auch meine
portion macht dass ich habe für menschen
einfach noch ein bisschen salz und
pfeffer war es ist um ehrlich zu sein
gar nicht mehr fallen lässt halt zwei
drei sachen von rekruten das direkt aber
hier scheint es zu schmecken hat und wie
er sagen leute wir sehen uns da ich dann
auch gewesen ist scheiße meine nase hat
die gesamte schüssel leergefegt ich
selbst hab sogar noch ein bisschen was
würdest du den ganzen geben ist war
wirklich geisteskrank lecker 10 von 10 c
okay das ist stabil
10 von 10 100 prozent sehr gut da wie
man sieht auch das ist ja nicht komplett
oder abendessen sind auch so lecker sein
okay ich gebe mir mühe leute sagen wir
sehen uns gleich beim abendessen
bist du noch im wasser hast du ein abo
da so freuen wir kommen auf dem
abendessen soll ich für diese
lichtverhältnisse ich habe leider nicht
daran gedacht mir selbst noch eine video
lampe mitzunehmen
deshalb ist es perfekt hier ist ein
superheld wir machen uns einen burger
den hat er sich von mir gewünscht
beziehungsweise ich dachte wir natürlich
mittlerweile ist das mich in bürger auch
schon so ein running gag fast jeder sich
bürger von mir wünscht und hafen und
schreibtische wieder bürger endlich
erfüllt wünsche aber wenn sie sich jetzt
ein wünscht dass sich das schon machen
ich weiter 100 bürger für pittis
benutzen wir den kilt horst dinkel
verträgt sam am besten da dachte ich mir
ich einfach diese toastscheiben am ende
des tages marxheim droht gar nicht super
gerne dementsprechend schlecht daraus
jetzt einfach so ein kleines rundes
petit traumhaft oder oben und unten
kochst du wieder da bist du schon mal
ein bisschen ruhe probieren ja lecker
dann haben wir auch schon weiteren
formen das in partie das ist ein
bisschen traurig aber es besteht einfach
nur aus hackfleisch einfach ein bisschen
durchkneten ich weiß nicht ob es
überhaupt irgendjemand erwartet hatte
aber es gibt heute keine krassen
ausgefallenen rezepte sondern wir machen
aber sagen dies allen gut schmecken
doch der schon wieder bock langsam
versteht es läuft auch was abgehen
verstehe ich schon die ganze zeit was
laberst du also unser patty ist fertig
dann machen wir unsere fahne an und bei
dem was heute morgen so gut geschmeckt
hat machen wir noch ein bisschen becken
auf den burger und sames absolutes
lieblings lebensmittel käse immer wenn
er irgendwie hört dass so ein käse
packung was für richter käse käse käse
ich glaube das wird auf jeden fall ein
gebührendes finale für den heutigen tag
jemand den becken in die pfanne
wir werden jetzt mal den bänken und dann
holt ihn auch schon raus und leute im
becken fed warten wir jetzt das
kartieren
während das hier so vor sich hin dreht
fraglich keiner anderen tauchst du den
tod und dann leute ganz wichtig käse
umbruchs schön knusprig dann nehmen wir
uns jetzt von frischkäse weil ich glaube
dass frisch gehen sie war zum großen
teil dafür verantwortlich dass ihn heute
so gerne das mittagessen gegessen hat
das ersetzt fürs handy ketchup und mayo
dann kommt jetzt auch unser vertrieb
füllen hier so drauf und dann klappen
wir auch schon unsere hunde bürger zu
[Musik]
das letzte mal dass ich heute fühle ich
koche schade ist so aufgeregt ja bin ich
ich habe hier ein bürger für sich
gezaubert hat das hatte ich noch nie
also bankenmarkt gehen oder ja weißt
doch dann habe ich käse käse jeder weiß
dass der käse liebsten dem geldhaus brot
ist ja am besten bekömmlich für dich
bereit aber hoch guten appetit
danke perfekt für die kamera gemacht wie
soll ich das essen
ich bin kein mensch das ist zu groß was
verstehst du nicht da ist ja noch mehr
wegen strecke ist aber immer noch nicht
ich gebe auf sagen ein junger ich habe
einfach keine hände wie soll ich das
denn essen geht doch es hat mir aber
gesagt dass es ihm zu groß ist und
deshalb schneide ich dass man ein
bisschen klein nach endlich wenn man das
so schmeckt ja geistes lecker alter
machart ließ kaum das haus jetzt
komplett weg ich jetzt sagen wir sehen
uns gleich wieder den aufgegessen ist so
der letzte bissen alles aufgegessen mal
wieder das hat geschmeckt und normal
also sehen was würdest du sagen wie
fandest du den tag der beste tag meines
lebens
ok und das abendessen ich mein so lecker
moment der teller wird gerade noch
sauber gemacht
was würdest du den ganzen geben macht
man das einfach mitten im gespräch ab
und sich über einen teppich wollen lasst
mich was gibst du dem abendessen jetzt
für eine finale note ich konnte es
zuerst nicht essen ja es war ein
bisschen zu groß am anfang das stimmt du
weißt ich liebe wegen becken wieder top
klar ich sage insgesamt neun von zehn
neun von zehn wirklich jetzt das ist
stark insgesamt haben wir 26 35 das ist
auf jeden fall für den ersten hund den
ich jemals bekocht habe etwas was ich
sehr gut sehen lassen kann selber
wiederholungs bedarf oder war nur hat
ist ja wir sehen uns nächste woche am
sonntag spätestens wieder wenn ich mal
wieder für menschen koche ich weiß hunde
es auch cool vielleicht gibt noch ein
paar zwei wenn es euch gefällt mach s
gut bis dahin und schießt
[Musik]